this episode of the shob hot takes is
brought to you by happy hippo kratom
anything you see that i do the million
podcasts that i do the thousands of
stand-up comedy sets i do around town
all around the world i'm always on one
thing one thing only a lot of whiskey a
lot of kratom
i don't trust just any kratom though it
has to be all natural pure kratom listen
kratom's the wild west out there it's
like cbd back in the day you don't know
what's in there you know who you can
trust but i can trust my friends at
happy hippo because it's the best kratom
on the frickin planet it's my limitless
pill i swear by it i love it if you want
to try kratom out happy hippo is your
go-to go to happyhippo herbals.com promo
code thickboy
sonnen now chael went on his platform
which is a great platform the chael
sonnen uh youtube channel jail's one of
my favorite people on the planet he's a
brother from a portland mother but
here's the thing chill goes on to say
that he likes jake paul versus robbie
lawler it makes a lot of sense
and i couldn't disagree any more with my
friend chael sonnen he's one of the most
brilliant minds out there but he is
dead wrong on this robbie large don't
make any sense tail robbie lawler is
currently still tied up in a multi-fight
deal with the ufc and we know how that
goes they're not letting him out of that
thing also when you think about it
robbie lawler lost to
tyron woodley who jake paul beat twice
so there's not a huge huge appetite for
that fight now listen i'm a huge robbie
lawler fan i'd watch him fight anybody
on any given day including jake paul but
would the casual viewer tune into that
maybe it's an exciting fight it's never
happening though the odds are more
likely that
dana white releases nate diaz because
he's alluded to that and said the fight
that makes most sense for nate is to
fight jake paul
well let him go release him for god's
sakes man do us all a favor clearly nate
doesn't want to be in the ufc unless you
give him a huge fight you said it's
tough to find him a fight and dana
alluded to let him go so dude let the
guy go so jake can make all the money in
the world and nate makes all the money
in the world we're all dying to see that
fight we're probably gonna get it two or
three times sign me up take my money
bottom line is robbie lawler makes no
sense because he's under contract with
the ufc
you guys always forget that yo but
connor did it different animal we're not
talking about conor mcgregor we're
talking about robbie lawler right now so
he still has some fighting left to do in
the ufc if he wants but either way he's
not going to retire right off in the
sunset and fight jake paul dana's not
letting that happen but i do think he
will let that happen with nate diaz and
i hope that happens
now in regards to jake paul
well he announced that tommy fury is out
of the fight for
a gigillion excuses the guy totally just
went mi and ghosted jake paul in the
biggest fight of his career
way to go tommy fury
so jake paul to do something had to do
something fast his fight is august 6
mass square garden i don't know if you
guys know this but that place is not
small you gotta sell some tickets
so jake goes oh i know what i'll do i'll
fight haseem ramen jr
now you know his dad who's a legendary
boxer beat lennox lewis but this is his
son has over a hundred amateur fights
he's 12-1 as a pro he's fought at
heavyweight this fight is at
cruiserweight either way
awful idea for jake paul his brother
logan paul and his manager both do not
agree with him taking this fight yet
jake's still doing it
this is a much tougher fight this is to
me jake looking for validation from the
fight community if jake were to beat
haseem rahm and junior
if that
doesn't sway you over to be a jake paul
fan then nothing's gonna get it done
this is a much more dangerous fight this
is a harder fight the guy has a hundred
amateur fights for god's sakes look at
some of your favorites canelo alvarez
earl spence jr
crawford freaking uh
tyson fury deante waller look at who
they fought in their fifth fights it
doesn't look like jake paul's opponent
so hats off to jake paul this is a much
tougher fight much lesser known fighter
so i don't know how the pay-per-view is
gonna do but i wish him the best my god
jake you bit off a lot here i hope you
get it done we're rooting for you here
but god damn it's gonna be a tough fight
good luck jake paul